-Here's how it will work.
The two of you will
take your turns
doing your best pratfalls
in three different categories.
And Questlove, Tariq, and Kirk,
from The Roots,
will award you a score
of 1 to 10.
-Mm-hmm.
-And, Kevin,
since you're our guest,
you will start us off
in the first round.
-Okay.
-Attempting to sit in a fragile
office chair.
-Okay.
-Okay --
-Attempting to sit
in a fragile --
-It's fragile.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Attempting to sit
in a fragile --
-Kevin?
[ Cheers and applause ]
Whenever you're ready.
-Okay.
[ Jazzy music playing ]
[ Groans ]
[ Sighs ]
♪♪
This is crazy.
-[ Jimmy laughing ]
♪♪
-Jimmy, Jimmy --
[ Laughter ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Oh, my God!
Oh, my God!
Oh, ha ha --
-Jimmy?
[ Laughter ]
-Thank you.
-And the --
-Oh, my God!
-Thank you.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Oh, my God.
-Thank you. Thank you.
-Let -- can we see that --
can we see that again
in slow motion?
He's hanging the phone.
And then he gets thrown across.
-And he -- he loses his balance.
He loses his balance.
Oh, my God.
-Wow. And now --
-Thank you.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Thank you.
-And now for the score.
Judges?
-Yeah. Yeah. Yeah! Yes.
-7, 10, 8. Oh, my gosh!
-Yes! Yeah!
-So a combined total of 25.
-Oh, that was great.
Awesome work.
I don't know why I'm doing this.
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
[ Laughs ]
-Follow that, man.
-Ah, I can't.
-This, attempting to sit...
-Come on, baby.
...in a fragile office chair.
-[ Exhales ]
-Whenever you're ready, go.
-Okay.
♪♪
Uh, yes.
I should sit down for this?
[ Light laughter ]
Oh.
Maybe I should stand for this.
[ Laughter ]
No, just tell me.
I'm a man.
[ Light laughter ]
Okay. I'll sit down.
[ Laughter and applause ]
♪♪
Uh, ah, uh-ah --
[ Grunting noises ]
-Excellent.
-That was -- that was very nice.
-That was very nice.
-Very --
-Now let's see that
again in slow motion.
-That was some nice --
-Oh, start with the crusher.
-No, that wasn't enough.
It was --
I could have done better
in that first fall.
-No, that was a nice one.
-And then I was trying to get --
the cord was wrapped
around my neck,
but I was trying
to get it faster.
-Right. So, you did
the Boston Strangler.
[ Light laughter ]
-So, I did --
I pulled the Boston Strangler
there.
-Right there.
-A very important call,
obviously.
-Yeah. Right?
-A very important call, yeah.
And then -- yeah, I basically,
yeah --
-Now the choking.
-The choking and -- yeah.
And then that's it right there.
-Fantastic. Now --
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Yeah.
-For the score. Judges?
[ Applause ]
[ Audience awws ]
6, 10, and 1
for a total of 17.
Wow!
-Ah, that's --
-Un --
-Wow!
-First of all, I want to say,
Questlove, you're my next guest.
So, yeah. Thank you very much.
[ Laughter ]
-That brings us to round two.
Tripping on a Cheeto.
Jimmy, you're up.
Good luck.
You're perfect.
-Tripping on a Cheeto.
Remember, you're perfect.
Tripping.
-Yeah.
-Tripping on a Cheeto?
-Can we get a shot
of that Cheeto?
There's that Cheeto.
[ Laughter ]
Right there. You're going to
trip on that Cheeto.
-So I don't know it's there.
-No, you do not know it's there.
-Okay.
-You're walking very casually.
That Cheeto trips you up.
-Here we go. [ Clears throat ]
-Whenever you're ready.
♪♪
-No.
[ Laughter ]
[ Clears throat ]
[ Laughter,
cheers and applause ]
-Oh, my goodness!
-Man!
[ Cheering continues ]
-Wow! That was a -- wow.
The double bracket.
-That --
-The double bracket.
Can -- can we see --
can we see --
-I don't know if that's
really a breakaway.
That's a wood --
it's like a wooden shelf.
-No, that was a breakaway.
-Be careful with that --
The breakaway shelf --
it's actually made out of wood.
[ Laughter ]
Am I bleeding at all?
-No, no.
-You're bleeding a little.
-Am I bleeding again?
-No, you're good.
-Can we see it in slow motion?
[ Laughter ]
-What's wrong with people?
-There you go. Watch this.
-Oh! Good --
-Double -- wham, whomp!
Bing bong!
-That was a great kick
and a nice shelf stick.
-Nice shelf stand right there.
-Watch this. Watch this.
-There it goes.
-Oh!
-Fantastic.
-That's a hard one to beat.
-All right, judges.
May we see the scores?
-Oh, that's good. I improved!
-8, 10, 7!
-You had to give it up.
-25. Wow!
-You had to give it up
on that one.
-That is fantastic.
-Yeah, yeah. I got that.
I appreciate it.
No, he's just keeping it real.
Okay, I like that one.
-Now, Kevin.
-Yeah.
-Whew!
-That's tough to beat.
-Yeah, tripping on a Cheeto.
Are you ready, my friend?
-Yeah. I am ready.
All right, here we go.
All right, let's do this.
-All right.
Tripping on a Cheeto.
-Tripping.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-What?
-He's got resin on his hands.
-Here he goes.
-You ready?
-Ready.
-Yeah.
-Okay.
♪♪
Oh! Come on, Frank!
You can't leave the Cheetos out,
it's very dangerous!
[ Cheers and applause ]
[ Laughter ]
♪♪
[ Cheering continues ]
-Oh, my goodness!
-Dude, he did the --
and he ate it!
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Thank you.
[ Cheering continues ]
-Wow!
-And the shelf stand on it.
-Oh, my gosh.
-That was unbelievable.
-That's a -- I love that --
-Dude, hey, can you get --
And he still has the Cheeto
in his mouth.
[ Laughter ]
So env-- how can I beat that?
How can I beat --
-May we --
may we see that in slow motion?
♪♪
Wham! Bang!
-No.
I'll tell you, I don't like
my -- I don't like my leg kick.
-No, that was fantastic.
And it --
-I missed it on the leg kick.
-And this thing -- it landed.
-Oh, my goodness. That is --
-A perfect shelf placement
on the face.
-Now --
-That shelf is hard to break.
-I'm dis-- that's a real shelf.
-It's real wood.
-It's absolutely real wood.
-It's reinforced with rebar.
-Trust me.
-And now for the score.
Judges?
[ Drum roll ]
7...100?
-Oh, stop it!
[ Cheers and applause ]
What do you -- who are you,
like Nipsey -- Nipsey Russell?
-Oh, my gosh.
-You're like Nipsey Russell.
-Combined score of 100 and 13.
-Come on!
-Making Kevin the winner
of round two.
Which brings us
to our final round.
-All right.
-Final round, which both of you
will be doing the same thing --
100 -- at the same time.
-Uh-huh.
-All right.
-It's the "ruin the wedding"
challenge.
[ Light laughter ]
-Okay.
-Will you be able...
-Yeah.
-...with your powers, to ruin
this beautiful wedding?
-All right.
[ Laughter ]
-It's time to find out.
This one takes the cake.
[ Light laughter ]
-All right.
-Okay.
-On your marks...
-First one...
-Get set...
-Okay.
-Go!
[ Bouncy music playing ]
-[ Laughs ]
-Whoa!
[ Falling noises ]
♪♪
[ Laughter ]
[ Stammering ]
♪♪
[ Laughter ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
[ Groaning ]
[ Laughter ]
[ Laughter,
cheers and applause ]
-[ Groaning ]
[ Laughter ]
-Fantastic. Fantastic!
[ Cheers and applause ]
-You were --
Are you okay?
[ Music ends ]
And now to determine
who wins the overall.
Questlove, it's your call.
Is it Kevin or Jimmy?
[ Drum roll ]
-It's Kevin!
[ Cheers and applause ]
[ Bell dinging ]
-Happy birthday, Kannon!
[ Cheers and applause ]
-He is the best, right there!
-Oh!
-The one and only Kevin James!